today for the first time in
526 days the astros will have a home
game with fans
[Applause]
on the mountain for the home opener for
the houston astros is going to be
christian javier had a start earlier
against these oakland a's only went
three and two thirds but it is his game
tonight
wearing the whites for the houston
astros
swing and embassy we are underway for
the 2021 home season with a swinging
strikeout javier gets canna matt olson a
designated hitter stands in
their strikeout number two for christian
javier getting olsen waving
what a start to this game for the young
right-hander two out nobody on for ramon
lariano hitting 333 through four games
now the kick in the 2-2 swing and a miss
got a fastball by him inside and
christian javier strikes out the side
paul irvin makes his second start of the
season
second against these astros and really
one of the biggest problems he had in
the game was the left-handed hitter so
one out and nobody on for michael
brantley and brantley lifts this one
into shallow right center and that'll
get down for a base hit michael brantley
off to a seven for ten start on the year
yoda alvarez hitting 308 here's the one
suit pitch outside corner ring him up
perfect fish and a good inning to start
the game for cole irvine here's matt
chapman leading off
call third strike javier with four
consecutive strikeouts
his career high is eight and he is off
to a great start tonight moreland was
able to walk it off in extras this ball
hit hard altuve plays it on a line
altuve wasn't sure if it was gonna hop
or
he could catch it in the air and he
ended up making a diving catch for out
number two here's sean murphy
swing and a miss javier has struck out
five of the first six he has faced
correa hitting 280 in six games 357 on
base percentage a home run and three
rbis 2-0 pitch hit to right field seth
brown back still going back near the
wall gone
carlos correa
his first home at bat of the season hits
one out to right and the astros lead one
to nothing carlos correa homers for the
second straight game his two homers this
year now opposite field he has so much
power when he extends the arms lands
with colors i'm sure would have loved to
have had it but he's going to get his
opportunity
soft swing by andrews bregman bare hand
nicely done by alex bregman
andrews retired for the second out
[Applause]
3-1 and that is outside and high ball
four so tony becomes the a's first base
runner and these will try their second
time through with more canna here it is
challenging
kemp goes and it is a fastball and it is
lined to left field for a base hit kepp
will stop at second up in the a's trying
to manufacture something here with two
outs in the third two on for matt olson
down to one nothing there you go
on the ground right into that spot where
carlos correa was in the shift and
that'll do it for the a's in the third
inning and they'll send up 9-1-2 jason
castro one-two check swing did he go on
a breaking ball in the dirt the answer
is yes he did
and castro will abandon
the batter's box and he's gone on
strikes that's the second k for urban
night day in
arizona three two rolled on the right
side into the shift down to a knee to
make sure tony kemp throws the first
inning over one two three and
six in a row sat down since the correa
home run by cole irvin ramon lariano the
batter he's their third place hitter he
bats for the second time now ahead 0-2
on ramon loriano who waves at that last
pitch castro on it in a hurry throws a
strike to yuli
and loriana retired on strikeout number
six for christian javier jordan alvarez
struck out looking his first time up
shoots one in the left center slicing
away from laureano down for a hit
loriano backhands it jordan turning on
the jets he'll be safe in the second
base
yard on alvarez picking them up and
putting them down a one out double in
the left center it's kind of exciting
when you don't see him jogging around
the bases but he can show some wheels
when he can
here is carlos correa now a five-game
streak and home runs in back-to-back at
bats
that's a fair ball down the left-field
line jordan alvarez will score easily
correa headed to second rbi double for
carlos correa he's driven in both runs
it's two-nothing astros
they tried to come inside with that
slider
so that'll bring up elvis andrews
for being only
a two-month season it was a bit of a
blur andrus has a base hit he's gonna
hustle for two and he's gonna make it
so
i think that right there raised a
situation where you talked about earlier
where the left fielder plays
quite a ways into left center field to
cut off that big gap
elevated breaking ball and he's got a
little longer place to go to get to the
ball and it allowed anders to really
have an easy double
javier approaching the mid 70s in his
pitch count
as kemp sends one to right field pretty
well hit tucker back on it has the play
lined up tagging at second base is
andrews he will head to third
kemper tired on a line out to right for
the second out andrew's tagging up and
going the extra 90 feet
here's marcano one for two
yanked the fastball down and away ball
four
now 80 pitches into the game he's going
to face matt olson in a two run game
with two runners on
call third strike he throws him on the
fastball
javier picks up his seventh strikeout of
the game and strands two it's still two
nothing astros and these are trailing
two nothing they just have the shift for
bradley now he's back in and the 2-2
pitch is swung on a ball of center field
lauriano back still going back at the
track over his head he makes the catch
what a play by lauriana reaching up and
snaring that ball as it was almost about
to land on the warning track yodan
alvarez the batter he doubled and scored
in the fourth he's also struck out and
alvarez hits it well to right back is
brown looking up see later
euron alvarez with his second home run
of the year and the astros leading three
to nothing boy it's great to hear the
fans the second decker for jordan
alvarez a moon shot on a hanging slider
alvarez picks up his eighth rbi of the
year such an impact in the middle of the
order amanda have they missed him
shoots one the other way that'll be a
base hit for kyle tucker correa heading
to third
bald being dug out of the corner and
kyle tucker has himself a double here
putting runners on second and third with
two away see if miles straw can pick up
a two out rbi or two
straw shoots without the right field
line that's a fair ball correa scores
tucker will score miles straw two rbi
single it's now a five to nothing astros
lead
slider up don't try and do too much just
redirect it that was beautifully done by
miles
what a situation to do it into drive in
two with two outs
two out lightning for the astros a
couple of opposite field hits as top of
the order jose altuve facing a new
pitcher for the oakland a's
jose altuve drives one deep to left
field with the fans chanting jose jose
jose jose he goes deep in the home
opener it's six nothing i was just about
to say that was the first time i've
heard that chant in a long time yep and
he delivered on
a drive over the a's bullpen
and gives the astros
a six nothing lead their third home run
of the night
and he you know doesn't guarantee
success but it just it's a much more
competent stance and gays have got to
get more guys in line with that steven
rips one down the left field line that's
going to be a base hit into the corner
extra bases and biscotti will turn it
first and cruise into second as garcia's
rounding third to score the throw by
correa not in time as garcia gets his
left hand on the plate ahead of the tag
by jason castro and the a's are on the
board on the double to left down the
line by piscotty still one out here in
the ninth inning
hit pretty well long run mile straw
still on the move sliding catch on the
warning track mile straw
takes extra bases away in another run
for the a's elvis andrews robbed by the
astro center fielder brooks rayleigh
kicks and delivers
line to center straw coming in can't get
it plays it on a hop here comes piscotti
gets all the way through but piscotty
comes in to score and it's 6-2
2-2
swing and a miss got him on a high
cutter and that is the ball game
the astros are victorious in their home
opener their first home opener in two
years with fans
defeating the oakland a's by a final of
six to two